if you go buddy these deportation papers
are a sad reminder of the time George
Vincent ifeanyi spent in Europe he had
left Nigeria because he couldn't find
work he made it to Austria before being
sent back I spent on us he says he
wanted to get a job as a cleaner there
but it didn't work out unfortunately
everything was toned down without
interview without anything you know I
was repatriated back to Nigeria know
what's i'm happy i have my life with me
but when one is living a life without
meaning the life is nothing again in
life is useless Vincent has been back in
Legos for four years he doesn't have a
job or a home he sleeps on the floor at
a friend's place when he first left he
traveled to New Year through Libya
across the Mediterranean to Italy and
finally to Austria it was a more deal
the boat trip human traffickers in Libya
and crossing the Sahara people died in
the desert without water sometimes you
see people drinking urine you see women
passing urine you drink urine just to
survive the desert you know they attains
a lot of things some people don't even
make the journey to the the seaside some
died on the way there are no reliable
figures as to how many people from West
Africa try to get to Europe but
migration researchers say the numbers
keep growing imbues have this
misconception that the land is going on
the other side and so they will do
anything to leave the situation where
they are now so move over to a better
place so if the conditions and the
situation's economic and demographic
like you've mentioned do not improve in
sauce countries in Africa in developing
countries you'll find out that a lot of
this you
who are sometimes educated but
unemployed who are disillusioned would
want to find a ways out of the country
George Vincent if a Anya is now a
preacher not in a church but on the
street that brings him a little money
and it keeps his mind off the past
though he still sometimes dreams of
Austria yeah the work I'm doing now is a
good thing for me I go out to preach the
Word of God I don't want to be a lonely
person how you are living your life to
do Vincent says he has no plans to try
and enter Europe again now his priority
is to earn enough money so he can afford
to rent a flat of his own that is why
Jesus